لقد كنا نطرح هذه النقطة الآن منذ
بضعة أسابيع، لكن أحد الأسباب التي
جعلت دونالد ترامب رئيسًا كان بسبب
قضايا هيلاري كلينتون
الأصغر بكثير من تلك المتعلقة
بالوثائق السرية كمرشح
في عام 2016. لقد هاجم السيد ترامب هيلاري مرارًا وتكرارًا
لمعالجتها
للوثائق السرية مع خادم البريد الإلكتروني الخاص بها
وأصر على أنه يهتم بشدة
بقدسية الوثائق والمعلومات السرية التي
كررها مرارًا وتكرارًا،
لا أحد فوق القانون
في إدارتي، وسأقوم
بتطبيق جميع القوانين المتعلقة
بحماية  المعلومات السرية
لن يكون أحد فوق القانون،
أول الأشياء التي يجب علينا القيام بها هو تطبيق
جميع قواعد التصنيف وإنفاذ
جميع القوانين المتعلقة بالتعامل مع
المعلومات السرية، كما نحتاج أيضًا إلى
أفضل حماية للمعلومات السرية